passé en ph c'est chaque année un peu
plus cher entre 20 et 50 euros les 100
kilomètres en 2018 rouler sur autoroute
pourtant à l'origine ça ne devait pas
coûter en rond 1961 bienvenue sur
l'autoroute estérel côte d'azur la
première avec accès payant de francs à
débourser remarqué la technique de
l'époque
mais promis juré le péage ne sera pas
éternelle de toute façon ce péage sera
limitée dans le temps
ce péage sera limité lorsque
l'amortissement de l'autoroute se
rassurer
en attendant les prix augmentent leurs
frères se répète
ainsi chers comme ça du fait que en même
temps les sens on ne veut pas augmenter
encore et encore
je ne demanderai pas pour penser que la
gratuité des autoroutes chaque match est
quelque chose de presque normal alors et
la promesse de gratuité de 1961 envolé
le théâtre ont été ainsi créés pour
rembourser la construction des
autoroutes et non pas pour faire les
emprunts les ph finance l'entretien et
le développement du réseau
mais c'est surtout un sacré bénéfice
pour l'état et pour les sociétés
d'autoroutes 62,3 en 2006 les autoroutes
ont été privatisées vendu pour un
montant de 14,8 milliards d'euros en
moins de dix ans elles ont remporté 14,9
milliards d'euros aux sociétés
d'exploitation la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les sociétés d'autoroutes
font trop trop de bénéfices
il y à un trop-plein perçu et il faut
absolument le rendre à la route et le
rendre en partie aux automobilistes même
si l'état encadre les prix la hausse des
péages et général est même supérieure à
l'inflation chaque année
la pratique concerne quasiment tous les
concessionnaires
[Musique]